the Trump administration this morning is
defending the use a private email by
members of the president's inner circle
CBS News has confirmed that at least
five current and former White House
officials have used private email for
government business major Garrett is at
the White House with this story major
good morning good morning government
related business conducted on outside
email accounts that much is established
the White House insists no classified
information was involved it also says
it's aware and the campaign was a pretty
big reminder of the political and legal
imperative of keeping private and
government communications separate
president Trump's most trusted advisors
used private email accounts to conduct
official White House business senior
advisors Jared Kushner Stephen Miller
former chief of staff Reince Priebus and
former chief strategist Steve Bannon all
sent and received emails using
non-government accounts the president's
daughter Ivanka Trump only used outside
email while transitioning into her role
as senior adviser White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders was
asked Monday how widespread the practice
was to my knowledge
very limited White House counsel's
instructed all White House staff to use
their government email for official
business and only use that email to
comply with the presidential and federal
Records Act staffers are instructed to
forward personal emails over to their
government account within 20 days
Kushner whose attorney this week
admitted his client sent and received
official emails on his personal account
from January through August was asked by
the House Oversight Committee Monday to
preserve documents and disclose private
accounts that sent or received official
correspondence she bleached her emails
though it was a popular line of attack
for candidate Trump
the White House has resisted comparison
between this practice and Hillary
Clinton's use of personal email and a
private server while Secretary of State
to hide her corruption Hillary Clinton
put our emails on an illegal server the
use of private email accounts by senior
White House officials is not new during
george w bush's presidency senior
members of that staff admitted that they
lost some twenty two million emails that
congressional investigators wanted to
find those emails were recovered years
later and they had been stored on a
private server owned and operated by the
Republican National Committee Nora I
remember that well thank you for
reminding all of us Thank You major